là tu vis de comment
à évident
[Musique]
Staline depuis 1992 de l'autre côté de
la nationalités
dans le recyclage des déconstructions du
BTP béton couche de chaussée ou encore
terre sont importés de différents
chantiers dans un rayon de 20 km en
moyenne
alors quand le canon arrive on
réceptionne à la bascule donc là on va
effectuer un contrôle visuel et olfactif
on va prendre tous les renseignements
pour faire ce bon de pesée c'est un
métier qui est primordial sur ce nous
qui dispatchons derrière les camions et
ça permet à derrière de bien répartir et
de pas mélanger l'État en fonction des
différents produits qu'on peut faire
après validation le camion peut
décharger sa cargaison un opérateur
effectue un dernier contrôle visuel pour
éviter la présence de corps étrangers
dans la livraison alors là on reçoit les
matériaux bruts là on est sur la partie
déconstructions béton et on va donc les
recycler et on va les transformer en
produits les blocs de béton sont
concassés à travers cette machine pour
une transformation en nouveau matériau
routier appelé grave béton ils seront
réutilisés pour construire les
fondations des futurs routes les
premiers clients des prémates ce sont
des gens qui font de ce qu'on appelle du
réseau l'eau l'assainissement les PTT le
gaz d'accord ces gens-là ouvrent des
tranchées donc déposer chez nous sur les
plateformes et prima les matériaux
extraits de leur tranchées et ils
repartent à charge avec des matériaux
pour remplir leurs tranchées donc on est
sur 50 ans en Yvelines et c'est une
ville qui se reconstruit sur elle-même
tous les 20 ans en moyenne donc on a le
besoin d'être là et c'est une chance
aussi pour la casquette ici
iproma de Trappes reçoivent une
cinquantaine de cailloux par jour 70% de
ses véhicules repartent avec de nouveaux
matériaux pour leur chantier